[Music]  Oh Mimi touched down in Aspen with her  Christmas classic plane upon her arrival  the singer is ringing in the holidays  with her kids Moroccan and Monroe at  this luxury estate courtesy of Airbnb  with a snowy Christmas in the Aspen and  it's just my favorite but mariah is  apparently heating up the slopes no it's  not because of her daring winter  ensembles actor dancer Bryan Tanaka is  with her and I witness tells et the two  are clearly dating walking around  holding hands very affectionate and  quote always smoochy  [Music]  the pair isn't hiding their affection in  front of the twins this according to a  source who also tells et that Brian is  great with the kids and they like him a  lot and as he normally does  Mariah's ex Nick Cannon will be joining  them all later this week  [Music]